we've been guilt tripped we've been
guilt tripped about our past you you
don't have any responsibility for things
that happened 400 years ago and I don't
think anyone should feel guilt because
of the color of their skin I think the
reintroduction of racialized thinking
into our societies is one of the worst
things that we could do to ourselves
that's why I've been pushing back so
strongly against it I don't want my
black friends to be treated differently
because they're black and I don't want
my white friends to be treated
differently because they're white and
the fact that we now live in a society
where it's become acceptable
to say oh you're a white man or or
whatever and that is somehow a
dismissive thing that that like that
implies with that you have some sort of
lower value in the hierarchy of who's
allowed to express an opinion or
whatever I think it's outrageous I think
it's disgusting and I think it needs to
end